if you've ever watched the video about
the stock market you've likely heard the
term nasdaq but it's often used in
significantly different contexts
sometimes people are referring to an
index like the s p 500 or the dow jones
other times people are referring to a
stock exchange similar to the nizea or
the london stock exchange and in other
cases people are talking about a
publicly traded company called the
nasdaq
given all these different definitions
it's easy to write off the nasdaq as
just some gear in the financial markets
but the nasdaq is actually the lifeblood
of the biggest tech companies in the
world including apple microsoft amazon
tesla nvidia and google
what's even crazier is that the nasdaq
is by no means a heritage player in the
stock market
in fact the nasdaq wasn't even created
until 1971
for perspective the nazi was founded in
1792
despite this short history the nasdaq
has become the king of the modern stock
market so here's exactly what the nasdaq
is and how it squashed legacy players to
the top
starting with the origins of the nasdaq
we have the company behind everything
the story of the company itself dates
back to the late 1960s when wall street
was struggling to keep up with demand
this was because the 1960s was one of
the most prosperous times in the u.s the
economy was booming wages were
skyrocketing and the gdp growth was
through the roof in fact real gdp growth
averaged five percent throughout the
1960s and u.s payrolls increased by 32
percent to top it all off the us would
literally reach the moon near the end of
the decade so the everyday american was
feeling more confident than ever before
leading them to take a dabble with the
stock market this drove unprecedented
amounts of volume into the nazi by the
start of the 1970s the average daily
trading volume was 12 million shares per
day
this might not sound like much compared
to the billions of shares that are
traded on a daily basis today but given
that the nyz was only open for 5 hours
per day in the early 1970s we're talking
about executing 667 shares every single
second while this was great for business
the 90 had extreme difficulty handling
all these trades after all they didn't
get any help from computers so they had
to manually execute and keep track of
every trade that took place
seeing this rapidly compounding issue
the national association of securities
dealers or the nasd decided to create an
electronic stock market called the
nasdaq or the national association of
securities dealers automated quotations
and this gave rise to the world's first
electronic stock market on february 8
1971.
in the beginning the nasdaq wasn't
exactly an electronic stock market per
se given that they didn't actually
execute any trades electronically
rather they were more of a quotation
service that allowed investors to
electronically see the live prices of
the various talks listed on their
platform when it came to actually
executing trades however this was still
done manually but it didn't take long
for the nasdaq to introduce electronic
execution as well
over the next few decades the nasdaq
introduced one feature after another
from automatically tracking daily volume
to the electronic execution of trades
given the relative ease of the nasdaq
stock exchange a lot of investors and
especially traders flocked towards the
exchange
by the early 1980s the nasdaq accounted
for 37 of the entire u.s securities
market and it wasn't long before they
crossed the 50 mark but despite the
extreme popularity of the nasdaq it was
never that respected in fact the nasdaq
was often referred to as an otc market
or an over-the-counter market
if you're not familiar with this
tournament it basically refers to the
trading of stocks that aren't listed on
the major stock exchanges such as the
american stock exchange or the nizi the
term otc is generally used with a
negative quantitation as it's closely
related to the trading of garbage penny
stocks despite this negative association
some up-and-coming tech companies like
microsoft and apple who understood the
power of electronic trading start to
embrace the nasdaq this didn't change
the perception of the nasdaq overnight
but it did cause investors to take the
nasdaq more seriously after all
microsoft and apple were by no means
penny stocks the apple ipo for example
minted 40 million years and made steve
jobs a center millionaire throughout the
rest of the century the nasdaq dominated
the tech ipo scene and they made
groundbreaking progress within the
financial markets
for example in 1992 the nasdaq partnered
with the london stock exchange which
marked the first time the capital
markets of different continents were
linked together but unfortunately as the
millennium came to a close so did the
nasdaq's positive reputation at least
for the short term you see it in the
early 2000s we saw one of the most
painful stock market crashes in history
called the dot-com crash
fortunately everyday people weren't
really affected by this crash and most
of them didn't even know this took place
but if you were invested in tech
companies you got slaughtered and given
that basically every tech company you
can think of was listed on the nasdaq
the nasdaq became associated with
extreme speculation and massive losses
while this wasn't a great situation for
the nasdaq they continued to push
forward the financial markets by
leveraging the internet in 1998 the
nasdaq became the first u.s exchange to
offer online trading and the nasdaq
started using the slogan the stock
market for the next 100 years
the nasdaq also started acquiring and
partnering with a bunch of foreign
exchanges and they rebranded these as
nasdaq exchanges this led to the rise of
nasdaq copenhagen nasdaq stockholm
nasdaq helsinki nasdaq iceland and so on
and so forth so in the end the company
nasdaq is simply a conglomeration of
stock exchanges from around the world
but as we discussed in the beginning
this is not the only thing that they're
known for
if people aren't referring to the
company or the exchange when they say
nasdaq they're likely referring to the
nasdaq indices similar to the s p 500
and the dow jones the nasdaq offers a
few indices that have grown to be quite
popular
the two most popular nasdaq indices are
the nasdaq composite index and the
nasdaq 100. people often get confused
between these two and their nearly
identical prices doesn't exactly help
with the situation but there is a major
difference
the nasdaq composite index was founded
alongside the company way back in 1971
and this index tracks all of the equity
securities that are listed on the nasdaq
stock market which includes over 2 500
stocks
initially the index was launched with a
price of 100
and the given that the nasdaq composite
currently stands at over twelve thousand
dollars we've seen a 120 x return on
this index since inception for
perspective the s p 500 has grown 42x
during the same time period moving on to
the nasdaq 100 this is a conglomeration
of the 100 largest non-financial
companies that are listed on the nasdaq
the nasdaq 100 wasn't introduced till
1985 but given that it's not only filled
with a bunch of tech stocks but also
that it doesn't include any of the
slower moving financial stocks i don't
think you'd be too surprised here that
the nasdaq 100 has already produced a
100x return but it should also be noted
that when we experience a downturn the
nasdaq 100 gets slaughtered during the
dotcom crash for example the nasdaq 100
sold off 83
so if you're looking to invest into the
nasdaq 100 you definitely need to be
able to stomach some volatility anyway
the nasdaq composite and the nasdaq 100
aren't the only two indices from the
nasdaq though they are the most popular
there's also the nasdaq global equity
index the nasdaq golden dragon china
index the ph lx semiconductor index the
omex stockholm 30 index and so on and so
forth moving on from all these indices
the nasdaq also has their own stock
during the height of the dot-com bubble
in 2000 the nasd decided to start
selling their steak in nasdaq they
started off with a private placement
offering and shortly after shares of the
nasdaq started trading on the otc
markets and eventually on february 9
2005 the company nasdaq was listed on
the nasdaq stock exchange the ticker
symbol for the company is ndac and they
currently sit at a 25 billion evaluation
clearly embracing the digital world has
played out quite well for them
all right so the nasdaq primarily rose
to fame by embracing technology first
they embraced electronic trading and
then they embraced online trading this
attracted a bunch of tech firms to their
exchange and this is how they became
super famous but nowadays everyone has
electronic and online trading so why do
modern tech companies continue to choose
nasdaq over the competition well looking
at it from a common sense perspective
would you want to list your stock on an
exchange that has lagged in innovation
or would you rather list it on an
exchange that's led the curve the answer
is obvious but innovation is not the
only reason companies tend to go with
the nasdaq another major reason is cost
if you want to list 75 million shares on
the 90 you're looking at an upfront 350
000 plus an annual listing fee of 71 000
if you're looking to list the same 75
million shares on the nasdaq capital
market however you will be paying a
slightly higher annual fee of 79 000
but the upfront fee is significantly
less at 75 000
at this rate it would take 35 years for
the 9z to become the cheaper option
something else to consider is that the
nizea also has more logistical
requirements
for example all companies listed on an
idea must have an independent
compensation committee and an
independent nominating committee nazi
companies must also have an internal
audit function and corporate governance
guidance as you would guess none of
these factors are requirements with the
nasdaq so looking at cost logistics and
innovation nasdaq is the easy choice to
make however a select group of companies
continue to use an idea over the nasdaq
for a few reasons starting with prestige
as we discussed the nasdaq is often
associated with extreme speculation and
insane volatility and this association
puts off a lot of investors also it
should be mentioned that the nizee goes
out of their way to reduce volatility
according to the nazi website their
exchange is 51 less volatile at the open
and 52 percent less volatile at the
close so companies that are less growth
oriented and more stable like financial
institutions and insurance companies
often choose to list on the niazi over
the nasdaq this natural divide has made
the niazi the go-to place for value
investors and the nasdaq the go-to place
for growth investors this doesn't really
matter for the end user though given
that both exchanges are offered at
basically every brokerage you can think
of
at the end of the day none of the
components of the nasdaq are
particularly hard to understand the
reason that it's often confusing is
simply because the same name refers to
so many different things it would have
been way better if each of them simply
had different names but unfortunately
this is the system we have
first there's a nasa company which is in
charge of handling the nasdaq exchanges
then there's the nasdaq indices which
primarily include the nasdaq composite
index and the nasdaq 100 index and
finally there's the stock of the nasa
company itself over the past few decades
the nasdaq has proven to be a much more
innovative exchange with much looser
policies which has made them a favorite
amongst growth companies but a lot of
companies in legacy industries continue
to prefer the nazi and that's the nasdaq
explained if you were the owner of a
multi-billion dollar company would you
list on the nasdaq or the nazi comment
that down below
also drop a like if you thought this
video explained the nasdaq well and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch your
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]
you